we've had private conversations now
where you we've said to each other let's
not talk about that maybe the next time
you come on the air you talk about now
one of those conversations was you turn
to me and you said this was at your
house you said to me hey tell me the top
10 favorite movies of all time you asked
me that right and we started to talk
about it and I said don't talk about
this we'll talk about it on the air okay
so what are your top ten we both agree
tennis too many five let's do three all
right give me your top I'll give you my
top three well I said to you at my house
Abbott and Costello uh meets
Frankenstein yeah and we both agreed on
that but it's not the top three we were
talking top ten I really loved that
answer I was really surprising I love
Abbott and Costello and let's face it
their TV show talk about Seinfeld the TV
show and talk about Abbott and Costello
Aberdeen Costello they had a great TV
show with all those characters right do
do you not see the similarity yes my
show and that I patterned my show after
that show did you yes is that the truth
or you're just saying that to appease me
no that that the idea of Abbott and
Costello was everybody is evil for no
reason right nobody explains why Mike
the cop hates Lou yeah why Mr bachigalu
is so hostile and Mr Bacha galoop yeah I
mean that alone how many we did tons of
that on my show right we had the street
like they had the street yeah the
apartment like they had the apartment
two guys who were just trying to figure
it out right me and George that was the
that was the Genesis of it and when you
and Larry David sat down and said hey
we're gonna make a TV show and NBC
agreed to make a TV show you said hey we
love Abbott and Costello no no we never
said that they would never said out loud
no they wouldn't even know what it is
George's middle name is Lou after Lou
Costello oh on the show did you ever say
to Larry we've got a fashion that's
after Abbott and Costello well I didn't
have to say that because we were both
similar mindset that this is just going
to be as funny as we can make it but you
never consciously sat down and said hey
our heroes are Abbott and Costello no we
talked about it because Evan and
Costello is a pure comedic show this you
know there's no story arcs where anybody
really learns anything or right and
that's where that whole thing about the
laugh all about the laugh it's a show by
two stand-up comics who only care about
the laugh right and you guys said the
motto on your TV show was no hugging and
no learning right right and and you
stuck to that yes I never learned
anything from an episode of Seinfeld
right no right and nobody hugged no
just a bunch of people trying to get
through life yeah well all great comedy
even go back to Shakespeare Midsummer
Night's Dream everyone is self-motivated
self-interested and that's where that's
that's how you build comedy
foreign